- Hi, everyone.
Hope you're all having a good day.
So right now I'm here in Munich
at our office, at Building Radar.
So some of you probably already know,
I currently work in a role
as a Chief Revenue Officer
at this mature startup.
We are a company in the PropTech sector.
I recently also made a video
about what it's like to work here.
I will link it somewhere up here,
if you have not seen it yet.
And for today's video,
I want to talk about
a topic that is meeting behavior,
because I know that this
is a topic that many people
do struggle with, especially juniors,
and I've seen there's more
fear at Building Radar,
but also in my previous
roles in consulting.
And very specifically, often
people are in a meeting
and wonder what shall I say, right?
You feel shy, it's a bit
difficult to add value,
to contribute.
What is it that you can say
as a junior in a meeting
to really make a good impression,
make a good impression about yourself?
And specifically, I would
love to share three tips
for you here today.
So let's dig into it without further ado.
And the first tip is a
tip that a past partner
that I worked with, a
consultant once gave me,
and I thought that made a lot of sense,
and for me, really made a difference,
because I am as well,
I would probably consider
myself rather to be an introvert
than an extrovert.
And the partner told me, Heinrich,
in the beginning of a meeting,
make it a point, make it a habit of yours,
that in the first couple
of minutes of a meeting
you directly say something,
even if it's something small,
even if it's something
that's not that important,
say something in the beginning.
Because as a matter of fact,
it's so much harder, much more difficult,
if you've been sitting in
a meeting for half an hour,
for an hour, or even later,
and all the time you have said nothing,
to then suddenly speak
up and say something.
And the burden of that
will increase significantly
over time, the longer the meeting,
the longer interaction goes
without you saying anything.
So if you very early say something,
this will usually
significantly lower the burden
for you then to later on in the meeting,
say additional things.
And it sounds like a minor tip,
but for me, it really made a difference.
It was really, really important.
So just try this out.
I encourage you, and let
me know in the comments
whether this is making a
difference for you as well.
Tip number two is about
proper preparation.
So surely it will be much
easier for you to contribute
and to add value to meetings,
if you prepare in the right way.
And very specifically, what
I would recommend you to do
is before you are in the meeting,
before the meeting starts,
to take the meeting document,
look at it,
and really think about
what could be questions
that you may be sensibly ask
at specific points of the document.
Maybe to some other members, to clients,
why it would insightful
to know more about that,
or what would be helpful remarks
that you can make on top of the document.
And here it's not even necessary
to have something to say
every single minute,
but if during the course of a meeting,
you say two or three smart
things, ask some smart questions.
this will usually be more than enough
to make a good impression
and really to have, indeed,
added some value to the conversation.
So preparation is key.
Look about the document.
Look over the document before the meeting.
Write down a couple of points
and this will, again,
help you also to be seen,
to be more visible in the conversations.
The third tip is about
working in the correct
and sensible way with data,
because it's just a fact
that you as a junior
will in most cases be most responsible
for the data analysis,
for the numbers that you crunch,
the Excel models that you build.
And at least it would be usual
that then in the documents
that you have there often
will be some charts,
some data visualization
that was used to just put these
numbers into the document,
and here be ready
and potentially also
think about it in advance,
what could be key points of information
that you would like to share on the data?
What would be really
insightful for you to add?
Things that are maybe not
directly visible on the chart
What are likely questions
that people will ask you
when they look at this data?
This is usually where you as a junior
can add the most significant value,
because it's just the fact that
often even the project lead,
and for sure also the partners,
they are not into that level
of detail into all the analysis
that you do in most situations
like this, as the associate,
as the consultant, as the analyst,
to prepare these analysis.
No one is better informed
about what you actually did.
No one knows the models, the calculations
to that level of detail as
you do, because you made them.
So this is really your point,
your position of strength.
This is where you shine,
where you have the expertise.
And here regularly
project leads and partners
will also expect and depend on you,
that if there is a
question in that regard,
that you will be able to answer,
that you can pick this up.
And to the contrary,
this will actually often be
also a bad point of feedback.
If there are questions on
this topic, you sit there,
you are not adding anything,
even though you would be the
one who would be responsible
for this piece of work.
So be ready, be prepared.
Think about that.
What are likely questions?
How can you answer them in
a precise and concise way?
This is from my experience,
from my perspective,
one of the most direct ways
where you can add value
in these meetings as a junior.
So I hope these tips made
sense and were helpful to you.
I would also love to hear
from you from your experience,
how would you advise to a junior person
how they can speak up and
say something in meetings?
Let us know in the comments.
I trust, this would really be helpful
to many people watching out there
in the Firm Learning community.
I just know that for me when
I was a junior, for sure,
I was always wondering, what
can I do in these meetings?
What can I say, right?
So think about that.
Add your perspective.
I would love to hear from you, as always,
if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
Subscribe to the channel,
to stay up to date on all the content.
I'm also present on other
social media platforms,
such as LinkedIn, Instagram,
Tik TOK, and Twitch.
Links to these socials
in the video description.
Big, big thank you to all
the members of Firm Learning.
Thanks so much for your contribution.
You're really making a
difference for the work here
on the channel.
So I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday,
here on Firm Learning.
So good week to you,
see you again next week.
All the best and bye-bye.